in this video we will see the calculation
marginal pro liter and filtering
as part of hm
so we saw how to calculate the
probability joined this in a hlm this is
to say how to calculate the parity of pde
is up till you and h1 until you miss
but in what will be more
interesting fact since normally the
hidden variables are hidden
not observe we will rather be interested in
calculate what is the probability of
observation that I have in hand so except
that it requires so it's
marginalize variables that are not
observed the hidden variables in
too much what it means is that I
have to sum up on all
possible assignments of variables
hidden
I have to sum up their
probabilities x given the policy
to have these hidden variables there the
political this assignment of
hidden variables the rs and generate the
observations for which I try
to evaluate the probability so the part
marginal it is useful among others for
try to see to measure how much
my model let go even is a good model
for my data is what gas inc of
pro liter to observe observations
that I collected policies are
high or not so that's what we have
calculated to calculate the probability
marginal the problem we see here
it is that the sum of
all possible sequences of rates
cash and it's a sum that very very
big which makes it exponential so if
for example we were hidden took 2
possible value but I have two values
for h
once the two values ​​for h two
times both possible values ​​for h3
and so on until you buy
so I'm going to have two to act and
possible sequences of value value
for kosher states and that's it just
for the case where the states to cyprus 2
value if they take more than 2
valence that still sells this practice
will be
thoroughly the number of values ​​can the
variables n at the act and so that's
exponential it's something that gets
not calculate in practice so a calculation
naive from basically the
definition of the marginal policy is going
not and effective in the context of schemas
so what we're going to do is
that we will use a technique to
do this kind of calculation had operated
the structure of the hlm as part of a
dynamic program
so the idea of ​​doing programming
dynamic it's actually breaking down the
calculation we want to do
but intermediate calculations that we will
structure in a table and we will
start in a corner here that we're going
calculate all of the other 15 as
that and we will progress until we
calculated all the elements of my
table and there I will be able to consult
the elements of my chart at the end which
I'm interested in the interest of doing that
in a table like that it's when we
does that will require in the case between
others of the hmm only two iterations
iteration over the number of rows and the
number of columns and if he appoints
tidy the number of columns and small
bath the calculation is going to be effective and it's going
to be the case in the context of letting go even
could do the calculation that we are late
when we want to fage remember knows
calculate the probability for a
sequence that we observed that I noted
little s1 until t so if that's the
sequence the observations I have in
hand for which I will evaluate the
probability then the dynamic program
the big thing we are going to do is we
will start by defining what are the
table elements that owl
calculate and dance only if what we're going
wanting calculated is therefore the element of
table that I will call al fahm
the element monday two cols tidy i
'the index of columbia that's going to be the
probability that I observed from s1
up is this little and and that the
hidden variable at time t be equal
at 10 or
i of a possible value value
possible from the domain of but variables
hidden that's how I go
set the elements my table of my
dynamic program
when I have to do it is to do the
link between these corners there values ​​I
have to comp inc in my chart at the
column of the healthiest and bind him with
what I would have already calculated at the
Colombia what will make that game strong
make a pass from left to right
then calculated all the elements of my
array then by definition alpha it
is no longer a bath it's this probability
here here is the probability that
I observe the elements in my reader
rss
1 to a little more we just have to
replaced here by type the st
actually I was full here I had
tm and so the pop to observe that and that
the variable hidden in the state at the instant t
+ 1 be equal to what I the same
illicit then now this
probability there I'm going to write it as
following you'll see why it's me
allow to close reduction which of
make the link with the elements of the lake
holland therefore addresses this probity there
here in fact what I can do is
simply added the value the variable
random buy so if I had bought
less more a game here bought + 1
i still have s1 until been more successful
I'm going here too I just added
a 'buy' assignment to a
possible value j by cons for that
I have equality since for me to have to
equal in fact mowing marginalized
this random variable so I'm going
summit on all these possible values
here so if I sum up on all
values ​​possible to buy
I fall back on this probability here here
so I have equality now I'm going
take this probity June is there then
I'm going to break it down in fact I just
rewrite it a little differently for
the moment so what I did was
that I took the smells the observation
sgs was healthier
then I broke down in two
so if I talk about f1 until st and
then it was simpler I'm going to
put in the end so it changes
nothing i'm just going to give the elements
the probity but I go there again the
probity that s-21 jca-t be equal to small
is a gold up to that and that was
more a gala care is more a it's the
same as writing swiss
it's just a different way the
crimes is so now I'm going
take the probability that I have here
joined then I had compounds have a
conditional product so we know that
I can take if I have a distribution
on three random variables like that
I can still write it camping two
extreme xp ii x2 sacha x 1 xp ii x3
sascha riether ok so I'm here I
prefers this for four barred thouars
for that does not take so that's what
I'm going to do here then the equivalent
an exxon it'll be the first
elements that I have here maybe it's okay
peace of s-21 until you and peace and
pardon is bought by it's just the
first two elements here so kind the
probity attached to his is the interest of
do that that was my match
alfort that I want to do appears
after that I must have priority
of a second asset element but
random variable here knowing this
so I'll take bought + 1 the
manage purchased policy + 1 be equal
given that I bought either gala
what I have here
but normally I should have this
also s1j cat equals a small s1
until you're here it's not written if it's
because in fact given that https
galls is the random variable
bought + 1 it is independent of everything
that's why it's the case
reminds that in the task and even we have
bought like that here we bought + 1
unfamiliar slump bought + 1 and
then here I would have hesitated and then further
there over there I would have all the s1 then
st up to st - and to find out if sort
is independent of all the esses sacha
buy I have to check if the paths
are actually stuck if I observe
it's all paths between the s is
bought + 1 will all be blocked at
this one so actually if I
know buy buy more
interdependent of all
so that's why they do not have
appear here there is an independence
conditional then the path of two
I will deal with the case of this
victory there and there he stays now
is healthier here
so I see I was more a sacha
the previous random variable purchased
+ 1 and all others
labs here buy and s2 is
until is quoted now for the same
reason so if i add here is is more
a
again if I watch bought + 1
all paths between st +1 and buy
as well as st up to s1 until st in
all the variables here are their
way to st plus we are stuck so
that means if I watch bought + 1
if I suppose added value more
healthy is mentioned above is independent
of all these variables
so I have not put them right in
so my conditioning that's the reason
for which we do not find is this one
to incite and buy here right
now the reason I
the outputs of the sum is that one
notice now this term does not disparate
no j so they constant against
at j then normally they would be they
would have been here but I can
go out because the term is constant
compared to June
then from this bath I take this
successful equation and I notice that this
term there here it's actually the definition
even of alpha it is actually it's al
flip through but to be honest I got it
my place
the place to use here gj so that
it's equal to alpha jt so that's me
allows to calculate the elements of the tee
plus 1st columns in my table to
from the elements of the teapot
columns in my alpha array and
finally ben if I can initialize the
first column that means I
able to calculate everything my case my my
table from left to right and
by definition alpha has a it's the
probability that pedretti is equal to
little s hours and h one penny equals
a value give it that gave a
cinnamon clues and that in a hlm that's
simply p2a charity gallery times pds
have integrated little sister sacha who has
sung gallery so that allows me
to initialize the variables in the
world in the first column and then to
from there recursion that I have here I
want to be able to calculate the
second column from the first
then the third part of the second
is instituted since calculated all my
table once all my table
is calculated but I can get the
probability of all my sequence is this
logical up to incite by taking the
probity of monkeys up to st
and that ht is equal to a value lying
data can sum up on
all possible values ​​j and then this
term there it actually corresponds to my
last column the column grown up in
so my alpha chart is actually for
get the probability of all the
marginalized sequences I just have to do
the sum of the elements of the last
column of my painting so here is the
dynamic program that will allow me
among other things to calculate the probability
marginal for an observed sequence is
this small s1 up thies great t
so let's do an example to see
concretely how does someone get
in this example if I want to assume that
I have a sequence of size 4 and dense
that if but variable h
winds is binary 110 0 or 1 then
but observed variable is quoted are going
also be binary say you did
you can imagine that someone who
is in the process of transferring a signal that
is going to be the ht signal which is a signal
binary but there is some noise in
the observation of this signal there is to
say that if the person has transferred to a
moment t
the bit 0.50 and 0.9 I'm going to observe 0
but with a politeness 0.12 I will
observe a no sorry here with the
british 0.1 I'll observe rather then
the same way if the person to
the moment t but transmits the bit
a game supposed that some noise in
communication that makes that with a
quality big enough 0.8 I
actually observed a but with a
probability 0.2 I observed earlier
and then now to the model of
transition but I'm supposed to actually
that if it is more likely that the
person alternate in 10 01 01
to send several times 000 1
so that was illustrated by the fact that
the probability that I transferred to
the previous example 0 and that I
still transfer 0 the moment t maybe
smaller than the probability of
transfer 1 after transferring 0 which
0.7 the same way here if I transferred
forward I resume the higher type
to transfer 0 after that to transfer
again ok so that's it
assumptions I make in my model
to finance an initial distribution
which assumes that the practices first
symbol the first pit that I send either
0 or 1 is actually respect replications
our alpha chart from its
producers
I removed lancre for the rest so we
wish as firstly initialize
our alpha chart then as we have
saw her loudly for the first column
this is it here so it's alpha sy 1 for
different values ​​of i sava head the
probity that to songs of the galleries times
the probability of observing is a knowing
that h integrate this value of ibra for
the first element we only have that
corresponds to the calculations that the
probability of purchase equals zero
times the probability that from
ax is zero I generate or
that I observe they are equal to zero
so that's saint calais 0 because in
my other message observed s1 equals
zero and then it corresponds to 0.5 which is
here times 0.9 that are here this
last patented that h1 be equal to
zero forgiveness the part that went
equal to zero
knowing that h a tea gala 0 so saturday
0 points 45 that I insert in my
table enough of this fact the same calculation
but for purchase is equal to 1 and the other
it gives and praline 0.2 times
0.5 which gives 0.1 that I insert in
my table again that's it
to initialize my first column and the
part of the recursion that I derived
sometimes I will be able to calculate the
other columns so you have there
recursion here I will not tell them but
it's the same recursion that we saw before
and visually that means that for
calculate the elements here in fact I
am going to combine the values ​​in the column
previous then weighting them from
transition probabilities in a
observation reality also for
derive what I have to inserted into the
table to the next column
especially for the probability for
alpha 0 2 which is the ultimate proof alpha
0.2 ok the probability psn is equal to
zero ps2 equals zero or
because s 2 what I observe if it is
equal to zero and that h2 equals zero
so we saw that it was written
with 17 recursion there to know I take
my alpha element 0 1 that is here and I
multiplies it by the parity of being at 0
to go hide yourself at the moment a well
to stay at 0 she was in cash and at
like its more alpha 1 1 which from here
so in that if we were on the nose in
the poop hatcher is equal to 1 and there I
look what's to enjoy the tasks
or equal to 1 then move on like
the hd is zero and I take all
together then I multiply by ckoi the
probability that h2 is equal knowing that
she age is equal to zero that i have
observed s2 tegana 0 and the remainder of equal
to zero it comes from the fact that it is the
sequence that is observed for which
I will evaluate its probability
so I replace it gives the calculation
next and then I insert it into my
board
so if we did know al fallah
x the parity to pass from here to pass
from 0 to 0 which 0.3 because of that I have the
body the half associated with h1n equal to 1
yoga what is the probability of being
to rota previous to 1 then 2 to get to
zero
actually that's the case
corresponds to h 2 is equal to zero I
hopefully 0.6 and here I multiply by
the policy from h2o is equal to
zero
i observe s2 equals zero that they in
point
so if I do it all together
give also know that I insert
lamentable I'm doing the same thing for the
alpha case 1 2 which I will not repeat
the exercise here but everything that changes
in the background it's the probabilities here
are punished even so that this is it
all that change I reuse again
there it was dark then the time one if I
replace by the numbers it gives me
this value if I insert my
chart I go to the high column and
I'm doing exactly the same thing
until now rather than having been
equal to 1 as previously kind t he
there are two sleeves filling up
the healthiest column so the
column 3 so I show you the
calculations here quickly and I continue
like that until the last column that
was born the last column that is
four what do I have a sequence
of length 4 so I filled in at
complete word alpha board and hello
come here and now if I had wanted
calculate the probability that s1 is equal
to zero that s 2 is equal to zero that s3
be zero and that s 4 be equal to
all I would have done is the sum
of spells over that and that was my answer
on the probity of the whole sequence
now another policy we are not going
calculate with the alfa which often more
interesting in fact that calculate the
marginal probability is to make
filtering ie in an example if
so, but I only have four
observations I have the first four
beats of a message I received
but here I want to know what is it
did the last big one that I received is this
that it's zero or is it one and
when I would like to know it's actually
what is the probability so h4 its
equal to zero given the whole message
than
received until now or what is
the policy h4 or equal to a torrent or
the message I received until now
a conditional political base
so I can recess like the ratio of
the attachments on all the variables
involved know h4 s1 s2 s3 and s4 / the
sum of the numerator for all
possible values ​​2 h 4 on which
for which I am interested
conditional distribution so I'm doing
the sum here of hashes cap galleries
and all other observations fixed
and there it makes these contents all these
elements are contained in my chart
alpha they're right here so I'm doing
just replaced I'm going to have a
better 0 point 0 043 useful that is
here then if I have the sum in fact of
my column so either we notice that it
actually corresponds to the probablity
marginal the sequence is this it gives me
that the policy h 4 the last bit be
0 is still pretty low 0.07 is
just if i do the same calculation with hk
is equal to 1
all that actually changes is
liberator of the numerator it is
now the other alpha alpha 1 4 the
denominator remains the same
I get a very high policy in
does so I have a pretty heavy confidence
that the last bit is indeed a
is actually an error here here it helps
and 0 then 6 and 1 06 and 1
so what despite the possible noise
I have a fairly high confidence with them
I did receive skt garin and
it was good but the message that
been sent
so the bit was not corrupted in the
communication
so thanks to the table thoroughly we are going
also be able to filter
like that and reasoned about your
certainties about our observations by
relation to the hidden variables